uh formal synthesis including
explainable
uh synthesis and with that uh how them
thank you for joining us thank you ross
for the kind uh
introduction and i'm glad to be here
today and give you a glimpse on the work
that we are working
uh on with respect to reactive synthesis
so in my talk
uh today i would uh i will introduce the
problem of synthesizing approximate
implementations for reactive
systems and present both the automata
theoretic
and symbolic uh algorithmic approach to
the to the
problem so uh this work is uh joint work
with uh ryana dimitrova and van finckena
from the
uh cispla handle center for information
security
so from all the talks that we have uh
from the for all the exciting talks that
we have
heard so far about the reactive
synthesis problem we we know that the
synthesis comes with this big advantage
of allowing us to synthesize
implementations automatically from their
specifications
and these implementations have have the
nice feature that they are correct by
the construction so we have guarantees
on that they satisfy
initial formal specification but this
particular means that the tasks of
developers shifting from
implementing a system to providing and
designing specifications
for that system which is in itself a
difficult uh
task so the users have to make sure that
their specifications are
right and that in fact there is an
implementation that
satisfies these specifications
so particularly in reactive systems we
say that as a specification
satisfies uh sorry implementation
satisfies a specification
high if for all possible uh
sequences of input values the outputs
produced by this implementation satisfy
the specification so one important
and one crucial idea here is that the
the user has to provide
uh lot of knowledge about the
environments in these in which these
implementations
will be operating and uh
in in general without this these
assumptions on the environment without
this knowledge
we might end up quickly with
specifications that are
unrealizable so with the approximate
synthesis
problem we're raising the question in
case the specification is indeed
unrealizable can we still find an
implementation that at least
satisfies the specification
approximately
so more concretely we're concerned about
the problem that
can we find implementation that
satisfies the specification
on a given class of inputs that are
generated by the environment
or even further when we think about it
in this quantitative way
are we able to provide an implementation
that satisfies
the specification on at least a
specified portion
of the sequence that's given by by the
class that we're interested
in so let me give you an example uh on
that
so assume we want to we have a
specification for an arbiter
let's say the arbiter is serving two
clients
that are sending requests to act as a
shared resources via the signals r1 and
r2
and then the the arbiter decides to
grant them access via the signals g1
and g2 so and the specification
requires that only one of these process
only one of these clients enters the
shared resource so
uh one part of the specification will
include the property of mutual exclusion
where
only one grand at a time is given to the
client each of the clients
but we also want to have an affair
arbiter so we need to make sure that
if there is a client requesting to
access the shared resource
then this client will eventually get a
grant to access
the shared resources
and lastly we want to make sure that the
the clients are not kicked out of
their shared resources while they're
still using
them so the last property that we we
have in our specification is one that
says that a grant should not be revoked
while the client keeps requesting
uh it so let's say we gave it grant to
to client i and client i is still
requesting
the access to the shared resource and we
know that
client eventually will release
its grant then we should keep
we should uh allow the the the client to
remain in its shared uh uh
resource so in other words as long as
the client uses the resource we are not
allowed to to kick that client out but
of course under the assumption that
it will leave the
resource eventually
so by looking at the combinations of the
conjunction of all these
three properties that we would like the
arbiter to fulfill
unfortunately this type of specification
is unrealizable
and the the simple reason for that is it
could be that we have the case that
after
gaining a grant the client might never
lower the request and will not allow
the second specification for example to
be uh realizing the implementation
so although one of the clients will is
asking to enter the
new shared resource that client will
never get the chance to enter that
shared
resource now
we can fix this because in general it's
not that
the environment there are no
restrictions on the environments that
these systems are operating so for
example we could say that
we the system is operating environment
where we know that each client
is eventually going uh to release
the grant within a fixed bounded number
of
steps or it will stay there forever in
the sense that this client becomes
unresponsive but if the client comes
unresponsive
then it's okay to to kick the client out
of the shared
resources and having this this
assumption on
the environment will make the
specification immediately
realizable because now we can just wait
a fixed number
of steps namely those given by the by
the bound on how long
the client might remain in the shared
resources
and then if the client exceeds this
bound we'll just say
okay client became in response
responsive and then we
just revoke the grant and allow the
second client to enter
the resource now the question is how can
we specify that so there has been
several works on how to add assumptions
to
uh the uh to the environments so many of
these approaches
uh will extend the um the specification
itself
with with properties new properties that
define exactly these assumptions on on
the environments
a lot of been work on on doing so
some of the work relied on encounter
guide counter example guided approach to
add these types of assumptions
um there has been also work on looking
at
the counter strategies of the
environment in a refinement loop and
then
based on these counter strategies add
new formula or new requirements to to
the specification that
will make the specification realizable
there are other approaches that tend to
have
assumptions on the structure of strategy
of environment
strategies so for example we could have
the assumption that we know that the
environments
are presented by strategies of bonded
size so we're restricting the behavior
of
the environment by restricting the
syntactic structure of these
environments
and in my talk today we're moving uh
along the lines of
adding structural assumptions on on the
environments
but in a new way namely by saying
instead of bounding the size of the
environment or the strategies of the
environment
we're going to bound the input behavior
of the environment so
the size of input sequences that are
produced by
the the environment and this idea is
based on on
the key point that if we are dealing
with environment that have a bound on
their structures or on
bound for example then we also know
that they have a bound on the on the
shape of inputs or the size of inputs
that they're
producing more concretely since we know
there to refine it we can characterize
the behavior of these environments by
the
set of input sequences that are defined
as ultimately periodic word and this is
what we will base our approach on
today so the main the main ingredient of
our approach is that we say that the
inputs generated by the environment
are represented by ultimately periodic
works and then we define a bound on
these ultimately periodic words
so on on the length of representations
of these ultimately periodic
uh words and we call these
representations lassos
so lassos define a pair of of two
implement sequences so we have
the stem u and and then the period uh v
and then we say that uh a lasso is of
size k if
the total uh length of u concatenated
with v
is less or equal to k and then the input
induced by
this lasso is the one given by the
ultimately periodic word u v omega
and now the synthesis problem becomes
this question on
can we find k less or precise
implementations that satisfy
our property so what this means exactly
is if we have a specification pi
we're looking for an implementation that
satisfies the property phi
on input sequences that are
representable by losses of length
at most k and
in its quantitative versions and its
quantitative variant will
just add the the portion on which uh
this implementation of the portion of
input inputs on which these
implementations
satisfy the property so here we're
talking about
epsilon k approximate implementations
and by that mean okay
we want to have an implementation that
satisfies p on
at least 50 of the inputs or 90
of the inputs off that can be
represented by
losses of length okay
and in in the first part of my talk i
will
will take first a look at the equality
problem so we
look at the synthesis problem again but
now we have a new input namely
the length of the input lassos
and then what we're looking for is if
the
spec is not realizable then is it at
least realizable
on the given class of inputs
representable by
k-lessons all right
so i will start with a um an automata
based algorithm on how to solve this
problem
and then i'll move later to see how we
can encode that in a symbolic way
using quantified boolean expressions
and after that we'll move to the
quantitative variant of the problem and
see how we can solve that problem
as well so let's start with the
automata based approach
so the idea of the automata based
approach is
again we want phi to satisfy the inputs
representable by at most
k of length at most k and for all
the other behaviors the spit the
implementation maybe think arbitrarily
on
the inputs so the specification may
violate the implementation may violate
the specifications for
input behaviors that are only
representable by lessons larger than
k so more concretely
the language that we're looking for the
language that should be described by the
automaton that we're looking for is
one that considering v we first separate
fee into these two spaces the first
space is one that defines
input behaviors representable by k
muscles
and the the complement set of that and
then what we are interested in
is an over approximating this problem so
we're looking for an automaton
that defines the language of
k lessos so inputs of that representable
by k lassos
and over approximates uh the rest
so the precision is then based just on
the set of k
uh losses we need to make sure that
violations on k-lessons are not accepted
by the automaton
and all the others are accepted by the
autonomous
all right so how do we construct such
automotive we we do that
in two steps so assume we're giving a
deterministic parity automaton that
describes the
specification we're interested in
synthesizing or in synthesizing
implementation for
so the first step is to characterize the
set of klso
input sequences and we do that by
constructing a dfa
that accepts a word or prefix a word if
it's a prefix
of one of these chaoses
and now having characterized this set
what we do is we compute
a product between the the set
this this automator defining these
prefixes and the original automaton
defining
the specification
so and having done that what we'll end
up with we will have an automaton that
represents exactly
this over approximation set here and
this automaton
accepts everything that originally
satisfies the property
of v or if it doesn't then
it uh at least have to be a prefix
of uh something that is rejected by the
automaton ak and rejected by just refers
to the fact that
again we're dealing with lassos that are
not representable
by length is of less or equal to
k
all right so having
acquired such an automaton then solving
the problem becomes
as we solve any synthesis problem on uh
these
types of automata we'll interpret the
deterministic parity automaton then we
construct it as a tree automaton
and then we play the emptiness game on
that
tree and then the result means that
we have a k less of precise
implementation for phi
or the problem remains unrealizable in
case we haven't found such an
implementation so we show that the
the sizes of the size of this prefix
automaton is exponential okay and
there's a matching lower bound for that
so the total complexity of
this composite automaton is polynomial
in the original
automaton defining the specification and
exponential
in the bound k on the lessons
right so and this is exactly what this
the
theorem states uh here so with respect
to ltl specification
we remain double exponential in the
length of the ltl formula
and we are exponential in the bound k
to which is the new input to the problem
all right so in addition to this
automatic theoretical approach we also
provide a symbolic
approach so we're solving the bounded
synthesis problem for kls or precise
implementations here
so we have another parameter that sets a
bound on the size of implementations
we're interested in
and then the result is well we'll get a
k lesser precise implementation within
states since we already have an
automaton that defines that
we can of course use uh uh bounded
synthesis as
presented uh by by band i think by nine
seven shader
um which means that the the constrained
system will be exponential
in in phi and in the uh software for ltl
formulas will be exponential in
in phi and in k
we propose a more direct approach and
how to encode that using quantified
volume formulas
and i'd just like to show you the main
idea on how to how this encoding looks
and the encoding itself is polynomial in
the ltl specification and
in the bound okay
all right so the main idea is that we're
searching for an implementation of size
n such that for all input lassos of
length k the corresponding outputs
produced by these input losses satisfy
the
property fee so
for for the implementation we encode the
transition relations and the the output
labeling
here we define lassos as as done in the
bounded model checking
uh encoding of length k and then
we also need to define the several loop
start positions of these
lassos and then we need another formula
that does this matching it matches
the outputs that correspond to a certain
input lesson
in the current implementation that is
under consideration
and the size of such an encoding is
linear in the formula and then quadratic
in both the size on the implementation
and
the bound on the lessons
all right now lastly
i want to also tell you a little bit
about the
synthesis algorithms or the algorithmic
approach for epsilon k
approximate implementation
and let me just give you a motivation
why why these types of approximations
are
important so it could be the case that
we still have specifications
even after bounding the the size of the
losses for which we will not find an
implementation so these type of problems
will remain unrealizable
so let's say again we're looking at an
arbiter and then we have the variables
for request and grant
but we also have a variable that that
plays the role of a right signal so the
permission
to give a grant or not and we have the
formula that tells us that each request
should be answered with with a grant
but of course the grant can only be
given if uh
the p signal is uh is true all right so
this formula tells us
as long as as every time if the p signal
is not true then we're not allowed to
give a grant in the next step
and even if we bound the number of
losses this is unrealizable in fact
just look at lessons of size one where
the signal
p is always false so in this case we
will not be able to
uh produce a grant to allow the client
to enter the shared resource
so here we move towards a more
quantitative question so saying that
okay
it is true that this is also
unrealizable for bounded lesso
but can you give me the optimal
implementation or is there an
implementation that at least satisfies
on a ratio of uh input
lessons and and you will see here if we
look at lessons that were input classes
where we exclude this
one lesson where we only have not p then
we'll end up again with a realizable
implementation so we reformulate the
problem to the following so in addition
to k
and n we also have this parameter
epsilon and now we're looking for
epsilon k
approximate implementations with n
states
and then giving an epsilon what we want
we want the implementation that
satisfies this following
equation namely we'll look at the number
of
lassos representable by input sequences
which satisfy fine
to the total number of possible losses
so the total number of possible inputs
from the
input sequences from the environment
and then we want to compute an
implementation that maximizes
uh this fraction here
so what we show is we can just a quick
note that
here's your friendly timekeeper we are
now at
20 minutes so if you can maybe uh i
i need one and a half minutes ross if
that is okay
yeah okay so the key idea here is that
we can encode this uh
this problem this approximate this
problem as a maximum model counting is
namely one where we want to maximize
over the number of implementations of
size
n and um we want to count over
the uh sorry we want to see
yes we want to to find an implementation
of size n that maximizes the number of
inputs
for which the specification is satisfied
sorry for for the formulation
uh here so
this can be formulated as we as a sub
problem but where we have variables
defining the implementation of
uh the implementations we're interested
in
and we have another variables that talk
about the the inputs
that we're satisfying the formula uh
over and then
what we do is instead of just looking
for satisfiable assignments we are
looking for
assignments that maximize over the
number of inputs that are satisfied
and then existentially quantify over
the implementations that satisfy these
inputs
so the total size of this equation is
again linear in the formula
and it remains quadratic in both and
we have implemented a prototype for that
using
the kqbf solver and the maxcount tool
which
was uh implemented also uh it was but
implemented by
daniel freeman marcus lab and and sanji
tatia
and there is a trade-off between these
tools so there were some
uh solutions that were solved by the ubf
solar cake could not solve by max count
and in the other
way around but in general the instances
also become
quickly very large so improvements both
on the qef solvers as well
on the maximum model counting the tools
will
make the problem itself more scalable
hopefully in the in the future
and with that just let me quickly
summarize so i introduced the problem of
synthesizing approximate implementation
more precisely k
lasso precise implementations and i
presented explicit automata based
approaches as well as symbolic
approaches and then we also took at the
quantitative version of that
where we were able to reduce that to a
maximum model counting problem where we
applied
the maximum model counter max count and
were able to get at least
approximate implementations in case the
solutions remained unrealizable
i would like to refer you for more
technical details to our paper
as well as a follow-up paper on the
complexity of constructing automotive
that represents these
approximate languages that i talked
about here and with that i would like to
thank you for listening
thank you uh is there a question that
people could ask either directly or
into a q a
uh in the meantime hazam if you can stop
sharing so that suguman
can share her talk